what is going on everybody welcome to
another Matt plot lid slash basemap
slash geographical plotting within
Python where we left off we were
plotting some dots on this blue United
States here we got a Houston Boulder
going on red Houston green Boulder cool
stuff so anyway well what I was talking
about last time was you know what if you
want to customize the plot itself a
little bit well there's a few things you
can do right out of the gate one you can
change the size so we can do like marker
size equals 20 for this one and then
let's make this one's marker can't do
anything we can do marker size equals 15
okay so we can save that we can run that
and now you can see that you got a big
Houston dot and pretty big boulder but
not as big as the Houston dot that's
cool
but let's do let's take this just as a
really quick example and then do like 28
right I assume those will run over each
other so let's run this real quick yeah
and what if this one is a green actually
and we'll plot that so what shows up
here is just whoever got plotted last
right so that's maybe not necessarily
what you want right because you could
have in theory dots run over each other
and you would lose some some of your
data possibly if that was an issue but
again the size of the dot obviously it's
not changing so like when we zoom in to
just that spot that's not our problem
anymore right but let's say it is it's
becoming an issue for you or you do want
them to run over a little bit like if
you let them run over a little bit it
kind of helps the transition of color so
for example what we can do is throw an
alpha here which kind of makes things
see-through so we can say alpha point
five and then we'll just apply this to
both to all of these actually
hey I'll run that and maybe I was a too
much of an alpha but you get the idea
now they're actually kind of clear so
when they do overlap each other it's not
such a big deal so finally the last
thing I'm going to show you guys is you
know how you would actually expand this
because you always want to be able to
expand you could instead have a flat
equal and array lon equal an array and
or actually and Python these are
actually lists but anyway you can do
that and actually well here's what we'll
do we'll get rid of this this yes and
we'll do that and then like lat
two on two equals and actually I will
just get rid of these brackets there's
not really too much need for them it's
not going to make this list too long so
and stay well we could say is that is
like thirty thirty one thirty four
thirty three thirty thirty two so only
that this one longitude sorry for the
Skype message use thirty you arrows I 94
let's say negative one oh three negative
110 negative 107 negative that wasn't a
negative 111 and negative 150 okay now
then we're going to basically the same
thing here I'm just going to copy and
paste these variables switch them up
we'll make these off a couple these
forty this one's a 33 this one's going
to be a 31 this won't be a 30 this one
will be a 113 100 here
102 here and a 112 there okay
now I will do that lawn that's fine and
then this will be too too should work
just so you can kind of get an idea how
you would build like an array and then
you could plot that stuff up like that
right just to kind of give you an idea
you can build arrays basically and have
different varied data you've got green
data and red data so to speak so you
comply like you know employee versus
unemployed you could plot wages you
could plot all kinds of stuff
or you could plus sentiment that's a
great idea anyway
that's going to conclude my basic geo
plotting tutorials hopefully you guys
have enjoyed and have some cool uses for
that if you do happen to make something
cool like me there I wouldn't mind
seeing what you guys make with these geo
plotting tutorials there's something
else you guys would like to see feel
free to let me know sometimes I'm able
to just kind of add on to the series so
if there's something that you request
and I can do it pretty quickly or easily
or whatever I'll just do it in in some
cases I might have left something out so
anyway hopefully that was helpful to you
guys as always thanks for watching
thanks for supporting subscriptions and
until next time